when we look at dividing integers right
dividing integers
is really a mirror image and i'd like
you to write this down
it's a mirror image of multiplication
so everything we knew about
multiplications
we'll apply when we think about division
for example okay we know that when you
multiply two positive numbers
positive times positive
what is the sign positive or negative of
the result the product
yes it's positive right positive times
positive
that's no surprise so in exactly the
same way
positive divided by positive
will also be positive right uh because
multiplication division are really just
mirror images of each other just like
before you know how i said oh
uh five take away three equals two two
plus three equals 5. it's the same kind
of relationship happening
okay what were the other results we had
before
for multiplication we had plus and
minus what happens when you multiply
plus and minus
yes sure very good so if you multiply
them in that's result
when you divide them that will also be
the result make sense
what if i switch the order what if i
have the negative first
and the positive second what happened
when we multiplied those
when you multiply a negative times a
positive
again yeah you get a negative right it's
still the same
and so just like it is with
multiplication it's the same
with division there was only one last
combination that we had when you got
two different numbers right what was the
last combo yeah
divided by negative very good so
negative and negative
we saw when you multiply negatives if
you got both negative you end up with a
positive and in exactly the same way if
you
divide a negative by a negative
you also get a positive okay so this is
not complicated
right let's have a look at a few brief
examples um so you've got 107 there in
front of you let's have a go at the
first
handful
so i'm going to start doing something
for you you're welcome okay we have a
look at this first question
right 20 divided by
negative 5. and please do get in the
habit like i've been saying before that
noticing that negative and minus are not
the same thing
so i'm going to say 20 divided by
negative 5
not 20 divided by minus 5. like this
it's not minus infinity
this is let's think about the numbers
first 20 divided by 5.
20 divided by 5 you guys can do that
okay so um just the numbers will be four
and i notice that there's a negative one
of them is negative so
i've got a negative four out the front
okay how about one like let's skip over
to c
i've got here negative 12 divided by
negative three okay have a look at that
one
what do you guys make of that yeah okay
now let's have a look
there's not one but two negatives right
two negatives
so that's this guy down here right so
this is gonna be
just 12 divided by three which is four
okay now just underneath that i want you
to write something extra yes keep
our belongings through ourselves please
yeah now let me try and help you see
what's going on here and help you
explain a little more right
negative 12 right
i can write that as negative one
times twelve do you agree with that like
that's just having a negative sign out
the front
so this is the same thing in the same
way
um negative three i can write that as
uh negative one times three
is that okay do you see what i've done
so here i've got
one pair out of this number and another
pair of this number
but remember i can rearrange things here
right i've got negative one
and negative one when you divide a
number by itself
like five divided by five or 60 divided
by 60
or you know 100 million divided by 100
million what happens when you divide a
number by itself
you just get one right so this is going
to be
the negative one of the negative one
will just be one
times 12 divided by three which of
course you already told me
is four so these negatives are kind of
canceling out with each other
okay now you remember i asked you to get
your calculator out
this is about multiplying dividing by
positives and negatives right there is
one special number
that is neither positive nor negative
and that's zero right so question and
don't shout it out i want you to think
about it first
what if i said
three divided by zero it's not in the
exercise and you'll see why in a second
okay but it kind of begs the question i
can divide by positives i divide by
negatives
what happens if i divide by something
else okay
christian want to give a suggestion um
okay
nothing anyone want to suggest something
different to nothing
you get um like everything or you get an
under um
unspecified amount of a number because
there's nothing you can divide it by
because
i never yeah okay i get my tree okay
so let's think about for example if i
said 12 divided by 2
what that means is okay if i've got 12
objects and i divide them into
two groups okay how much will be in each
group does that make sense
and you guys know okay you'll have 6 in
each group
if i say what about 12 divided by zero
that doesn't make sense without grouping
idea does it if i have 12 things and i
divide them into
zero groups how big is each group i
don't really have an answer for that
now on your calculator there i'd like
your original calculator
and see what it tells you three divided
by zero equals
and what does it say this isn't your
math
you've done something funny yours my
calculator usually
it says i'm not happy and it flips the
table and it goes home
okay now what's going on here let me
tell you
what's going on yes um on my laptop it
says
yeah that's right but it doesn't give us
an answer what is this
as to why let me help you understand
that question sir
that's the question oh okay okay let me
show you what's going on
right 12 divided by two can you tell me
what 12 divided by two was again
it's six six okay now just like we did
at the start of lesson
can you turn that division statement can
you
turn it into a multiplication statement
with the same numbers
2 times 6. good
that equals 12. now let's just suppose
that three divided by zero was an actual
number
okay three divided by zero
was something i'm going to make it a
star okay because i like
because i like size
okay now just imagine this was a real
number okay
what would that mean what multiplication
statement
would go with this that uses all the
same numbers can someone tell me
what multiplication statement would be
the opposite of this division statement
have a look look at it carefully
zero times star i think it's going to be
zero times
my blue star which is going to be
well now hold on a second according to
this
it should be three but something's gone
wrong something's going terribly
terribly wrong
right zero times
anything i don't care if it's 12 or 6 or
a star
or nikhil zero times anything
should be zero
so this is why i always get asked this
question because you can divide by
positives you can buy negatives
what happens when you divide by
something that's not okay this is why
you can't
because there's no number you can put in
there that'll make it work okay